la vie c'est comme un match de basket je
jure c'est vrai tant qu'il ya du temps
tu peux revenir au score et gagner ce
[ __ ] de match donc si torres des
seconds et minutes mais là je parle à
faire mon pote vas-y j'ai commencé à
jouer au basket à l'âge de 11 ans et mon
rêve c'était devenir basketteur
professionnel ce que j'arrive à 20 ans
premier contrat à 20 ans à l'as bondy 93
je me retrouve à 20 ans avec un contrat
de cinq ans sauf que je me fais une
blessure dans l'accident d'abrutis je
vais pour courser des mecs qui casse la
voiture de mon père je me fait notre
force et je me retrouve en toboggan de
loose
c'est à dire que 20 en pro b on prête
dans un club de 4e division donc 25 21
ans 22 en quatrième division
à 23 ans en cinquième division
là je vois que je suis bloqué je me dis
bon bah tiens je vais essayer de partir
aux états unis pour continuer dé mes
études je me retrouve à l'université du
connecticut et sur le campus grâce à une
coiffeuse
je rencontre le coach principal de
l'équipe qui me donne l'opportunité
d'être un des huskies un des joueurs de
l'équipe qui est championne en titre des
états unis à l'époque
sportivement c'était le top tu joues au
madison square garden tu fais de trois
matchs par semaine dans des salles de
25000 places tu t'entraînes avec des
tops joueurs j'ai un diplôme tu
rencontres des gens du monde entier
donc moi je finis cette année de basket
avec connecticut et à l'équipe d'algérie
qui m'appelle l'équipe nationale donc
moi je retourne en équipe nationale mais
bref tout s'ouvre tout se réouvre parce
que tout était fermé un moment donné en
france et là je rentre en france et je
fais une blessure à l'épaule il ya pas
de chance et je rentre chez mes parents
rue de la mort à saint denis
c'est à dire que pour décrire rapide
pour ma rue face à l'hôpital
delafontaine fenêtre qui donne sur la
morgue 60 m plus loin foyer de personnes
âgées dix mètres plus loin un hôpital
psychiatrique
en face d'un distributeur de seringue
pour toxicos et moi j'habite au dessus
des pompes funèbres numéro 13
mais je sais c'est véridique et en fait
tu as pièces de retour aux sources mais
me défonce tout un émoi à l'issue de son
retour je fais une dépression mais je me
suis dit
tout cet échec forcément il faut qu'il
faut faire en sorte que ça devienne une
belle histoire et c'est là où je me suis
dit que le stand-up
c'était la meilleure façon de
communiquer tout ce que j'avais appris
pendant cette année et tous les gens que
j'ai rencontrés
c'est pour ça que je suis allé sur la
scène moi à la base je n'étais pas parti
pour être comique j'étais hyper timide
je voulais pas faire de gt gt blagueur
avec mes potes comme ça pour déconner
mais jamais je me serais vu sur scène à
raconter des trucs aux gens jamais de la
vie
mais je te jure que l'échec c'est
s'aider bonne note il faut prendre ça
comme des bonnes notes parce que c'est
avec les échecs que tu arrives à
façonner des victoires c'est ça n'existe
pas les mecs qui arrivent leem
ils y réussissent tout ça marche c'est
pas vrai c'est des mythos c'est des
menteurs c'est même les gens les plus
talentueux
ils se sont entraînés et c'est il ya
deux différences dans les sportifs pas
les mecs ils ont beaucoup de talent mais
qui travaillent pas est allé mais
comptent pas trop de talent mais qui
travaillent comme des comme des d'un
essai ces mecs là qu'on retrouve à la
fin au basket à la base je fais 1 m 74
pour 80 entre 80 90 kg selon c'est à
dire je suis pas du tout formaté pour
être un basketteur donc moi j'ai dû
travailler comme un chien de la casse
c'est à dire en vitesse en dribbles en
masse musculaire mais en tout pour
garder ma
ma vitesse et puis surtout j'ai été
obligé de les gagner un peu de détente
j'avais zéro détente donc moi j'ai
travaillé comme comme un sagouin jeu
lâchait jamais la faire je vais venir
avant les entraînements je repartais
après les entraînements pendant les
heures de perm au collège et au lycée
j'allais m'entraîner et en fait ça j'ai
transposé sa sur la comédie moi je fais
des deux trois spectacles par jour ça me
dérange pas le premier spectacle je les
ai sauvé j'ai fait 80 spectacles
j'ai pas lâcher la faire et si en fait
je me suis je me dis que j'ai ramené ma
discipline sportive sur la scène on s'en
rend pas compte mais voilà être
humoriste à mon avis et voilà c'est un
métier de charbon heures tu répètes à
chaque fois tu testes tu vois si ça
marche là si ça rigole ça rigole moins
quel type de rire tu as que tu peux pas
avoir un rire un peu plus fort et après
tu réfléchis aller à boxer les les
spectateurs à cesser notre cultive